this was London saying farewell to one
decade and welcoming in another in
spectacular fashion
Big Ben chimes for the first time in a
year
and the heart of the city was
illuminated by a stunning display of
fireworks and music for the hundred
thousand people who've been lucky enough
to buy front-row tickets it was well
worth the wait amazing it is an
extraordinary experience one raising was
it worth the wait tell me what did you
think of the fireworks
it was amazing it was amazing it's
beautiful it's magical it's beautiful
like the lights every finger sound
[Applause]
2020 will see the European football
championships take place with seven
games at Wembley including the final so
it was no surprise to see football
taking such a prominent role in this
display well a 20-19 was a year of
division the message tonight in London
is that this city from 2020 onwards is
open to everyone
[Music]
in Scotland Edinburgh hosted what it
called the world's largest street party
they used three point three tonnes of
fireworks for an incredible display that
lasted eight minutes an estimated
100,000 people were on the streets to
witness it
organizing all of this costs a huge
amount of money but it has sent a
message to the world that London is open
for business and ready for whatever the
2020s will bring and the Brady Sky News
in central London
[Applause]